depuis plus de 60 jours 48 familles qui
avaient occupé illégalement des
appartements vif en pleine rue à paris
la question est suffisamment grave pour
qu un rapport était demandé un médiateur
monsieur bloch lainé
celui ci a remis son travail aujourd'hui
à michel rocard les solutions pour
reloger ces squatters comme andy et plus
généralement assurer le logement des
gens à faible revenu dans la capitale
reste très limité j'en paye eu 66 jours
sous des abris de fortune depuis qu'on
les a expulsés ces 300 anciens
squatteurs dont beaucoup d'enfants ont
été longtemps oublié jusqu'à ce que
l'abbé pierre les soutiennent le
médiateur nommé par premier ministre
vient finalement d'obtenir 40 cette
offre de relogement mais certains ici
doute de leur réalité
alors la proposition est venue comme ça
mais je ne sais même pas si c'est vrai
ou pas parce qu'elle me dit voilà la
proposition arrive ça fait plus de deux
semaines à rien alors pour moi l
opposition la proposition une fait pour
moi c'est bidon sur les 47 familles 14
seulement aujourd'hui ont signé leur
bail il faudra encore trois semaines
pour que tout son ménage
selon le médiateur l'attitude de la
ville de paris qui refusait de loger les
squatteurs à retarder la solution sur 47
relogement son office hlm n'a offert que
sept
je constate que j'ai subi un échec pour
de bonnes ou pour de mauvaises raisons
puisque je n'ai pas obtenu la ville de
paris il fut ce que le comptage en plus
qu'au mode s il est clair que quand on
excuse paris paris nos logements ne peut
pas ou ne veut pas le gpk neuro le
chemin les immeubles anciens à paris ne
doivent plus être démoli par les
marchands de biens avec l'accord de la
ville déclare le médiateur on doit il
laisser les gens modestes si on veut
éviter d'autres squattent le comité
mal-logés n'aime pas non plus toujours à
l'initiative de d'occupation de squats
et pas toujours là présent par les
discussions
c'est l'inconnue encore connue la
possibilité d'autres squats des donc pas
écartée
deux cents foyers en effet sont menacés
d'expulsion à paris cet été
le médiateur a demandé au premier
ministre de donner des instructions aux
policiers pour qu'elle ne soit pas
exécutée